every film is different but the sort of
common threat I usually this is my
seventh film with Chris Nolan's we have
a established process that dozen other
directors I work with we don't we don't
do the same thing but with him he's
usually in his writing phase in his
house and traditionally I've always gone
in in that phase and we sort of had his
his old double garages in the art room
and so I try and give him visuals visual
ideas or cues for the film yeah again
every film's different so I'm dunkirk it
was really going in to sort of study it
because it because it was such a
well-known event we realized within you
know a week of sitting down at his house
it was he'd already written the script
was the shortest script he's ever
written and so we kind of sat there we
looked around his like we got to get on
the plane go to Dunkirk so I actually
met him in Dunkirk very early on and we
decided we just walked a whole Beach so
he walked 18 miles
we can't realize we couldn't fake any of
it we had to actually go and shoot in
Dunkirk and we had to do as much of it
practically it was occurred even though
Dunkirk so really it's a difficult Beach
to film on because it it's difficult
Beach to get off because it's got a
21-foot tide it's very particular to the
event and so we immediately knew even
though it was gonna be very hard to make
the film there we had to go and make it
there so that's kind of how I started
and we went back to his house and we
spent a couple of months just trying to
figure out how to achieve everything how
to how to do it with as little the
effects as possible you know how do we
do the flying stuff how do we do the
boats and so we sort of came to this a
further realization we had to building
up Mada of big ships and little ships so
then I actually took off and went kind
of around most of Europe looking for
ships you know looking for the hospital
ship bushes came out no I came out of
Norway the Rogue
and I was looking for destroyers working
destroyers minesweepers so we had to
build this Amada so we it was a sort of
very it was a very difficult film to try
and make practically so we had someone
find planes to decide to how we were
going to do all the ships whether we're
gonna scale them down we're gonna use
half scale [ __ ] and a half scale
destroyer is is you know 180 foot long
so you could you can use a boat that's
much smaller and then you have to build
the scenery on the decks and make it
seaworthy to make a full-size destroyer
over 150 feet so we so came up with all
these sort of practical ways of
achieving the film I mean we're not
doing anything new I've been doing a pre
visual effects for donkey's years so we
we we you know how do we put an IMAX
camera on a World War 2 plane and fly it
in formation and capture that on film
so we there was a lot of practical
enormous amount of practicalities and
that kind of to begin with over rode the
design theme and then you know as we got
further into it and we looked at other
research we realized that Dunkirk you
know everyone sees it as this sort of
little you know three-story seaside town
but actually was a big industrial port
so we really want to play with the the
the industry and the bleakness of of the
other side of Dunkirk which can't played
into our film thistles this lonely place
inescapable place there were very few
photographs taken of the event so
finding enough research was was
difficult but weirdly the Dunkirk
library when we finally got into it had
an enormous amount of photographic
research of the event so really that's
where we spent I mean the seed of
Dunkirk was phenomenal so they opened
their doors to us and that's where their
archives were amazing most of the troops
escaped on the east mole which was this
kilometer long seven and a half feet
wide pier white pier that went out to
sea so it wasn't there when
it'd been demolished over the years so
you know for us that was a very key
image this sort of singular tunnel why
here the rotor nowhere so that was you
know that these soldiers were lined up
on and that was a really key image but
you know like the big problem with that
is we had to rebuild that pier into the
English Channel so that was another it
was a big physical task too and we
rebuilt at six seven hundred feet of it
into the sea with a 21 foot tight it
became this giant logistical issue to
achieve a very sort of simple image and
that would go you know we had the white
pier the hospital ship we had these in
these sort Gracie's it was very very
controlled very controlled palette when
you look at the film and then we go to
the air so they were you know we were
running with all these elements but the
underlying issue as a designer was
trying to achieve them in these harsh
conditions I mean the we had like our
British Army we had 3,000 men that we
painted and cut out and stuck on the
beach so all the background armies are
literally old-school cutouts the
soldiers pegged out on the beach and
they spent like two months on the beach
a lot of the airplanes and miniatures
they're flying miniatures so the the
plane that you see Collins in is a it's
got a Spitfire cockpit it was a
two-seater yak that we built a Spitfire
copper in so the IMAX camera could film
information with the other two planes
all that is live so it's all very you
know meant a lot to me to try and
achieve everything practically but it's
not the easiest thing to do
pre-production became about logistics is
like we'd be talking to these museum
using museum ships that were sort of
barely running and we'd be asking if
they would be willing to sell you know
500 miles south to Dunkirk and be in a
film so you know again you're you're out
there with real people with real boat
owners trying to persuade them to steam
down to dunk
being a film and paying that boat boat
or you know we'd be in Holland and we'd
be trying to get the minesweepers to
allow us to shrink their turrets
essentially and put guns fake guns and
you know so there was a lot of there was
a lot of legwork and a lot of in
pre-production there was a lot of a lot
of legwork on how do we build the East
more how do we on a 21-foot tide how do
we how do we even start to build it
we've got a four-hour window to put the
steel plates in and then we have to
build it up and by the end of the day we
have to get onto the decking of that
session and then the next thing we have
to do it all again and so until we sort
of slowly step out to sea so it was by
far most logistical challenging film a
lot of people probably would give up
because those battles we have to try and
get this even the mold built in heavy
weather or persuade Dutch ships to come
over and with their historic ships and
we have to change them you know a lot of
people would immediately go to the
digital aspect but we knew we'd sort of
ruin the film if we did that so you know
it was a lot of legwork and holding fast
as I and it honestly it took every film
we've done before to be able to achieve
this because we knew we could do it it
was about keeping people with us to help
us you know the French authorities that
the mayor had to help the the city had
to agree to let us rebuild the mall we
had to keep our modder on the in the
inland docks you know and that was
before we even got to the small ships
and landed a real Spitfire on the beach
so you know so it was I'm very proud of
that film but when I watch it it was I
remember every day and so so that was
pre-production then we started filming
and then it's then you're on this it's a
big freight train coming down the line
and we have to always open the set and
then I have to move on to figure out
that the next day's work so Chris will
always say to me what are you still
doing you need to get onto tomorrow and
and so we always work ahead but you know
as usual we're working in more than one
country so it's a lot of travelling
involved so you're running three art
departments and you've got to keep
everyone moving
[Music]